shiny Vsauce
and the first episode of uninformed
video game reviews a lot of people
commented on the fact that Jerry bloob
has a pillow underneath his sweatshirt
why well he actually has a very rare
medical condition that leaves his
nipples razor-sharp so it pierces
through his t-shirts like this so in
order to protect his sweatshirt from his
razor-sharp nipples he has to wear the
pillow here's the July episode of
uninformed video game reviews enjoy
greetings all on the internet realm
Jerry Blue pier with uninformed video
game reviews the show where I review
games I've never played before
because Game Stop doesn't take food
stamps today is July now that summer is
in full swing it's important to stay
cool how do you do that no problem all
you need is a giant fan turn that up to
full blast mode a huge pitcher of water
and you got yourself a indoor sprinkler
my pants are full of so much water Ecco
the Dolphin could swim in them now that
I'm kind of dry let's start the reviews
the first game this month is Metal Gear
Solid Peace Walker for Sony's PCP its
latest stealth action game from creator
Hideo Konami but instead of killing guys
the snakes peaceful this time so he just
hugs them and not creepy hugs like from
my cross-dressing uncle Larry but nice
hugs like from my cross-dressing aunt
Larry I give this game an A plus plus
plus plus next up is Alpha Protocol for
the Sony 3 and the icebox 360 alpha
alpha alfalfa this game by Sega is about
alfalfa from The Little Rascals he has
an escaped hospital to fight the evil
Spanky in a pickle eating contest I beat
myself in a pickle eating contest I ate
seven jars also new this month
crackdown 2 which is exclusive for the
ice box crackdown 2 is like if Grand
Theft Auto and halo had a baby and there
was crack so it's about a crack baby
it's about a lonely lonely lonely crack
baby I give this game a for her ever
good the final game of the month is
Dragon Quest 9 for the Nintendo DS its
ninth one in the series so everybody
knows a story by now you play as Goku
who gets hatched from an egg and he has
to dye his hair blond so that he can
defeat his arch-nemesis vagina it's
really popular in the state of Japan and
I like it too I give it 10 stars all
right this is the part of the show
called game life is real life or I try
something out from a video game to see
if it really works this month we're
gonna try something from Metal Gear
Solid and that game snake eats rations
when he's hungry and then he doesn't
feel bad anymore so since my stomach
hurts let's try eating some rations
delicious rations
oh that's it for this month's episode
let me know how the new games are
alright so next month why this cat food
tastes like dog food thanks for watching
uninformed video game reviews if you're
wondering about the indoor sprinkler bit
with the water and the fan don't try
that at home but definitely try it at
church if you want to cheat the system
and watch the August episode of
uninformed video game reviews come to my
channel check it out you'll be an
insider and be inside of something
that's outside of you